we're all standing front of this
mountain and it's called government and
we don't know what to do with we can
scream at it and say go away go away go
away it's not getting us very far
there's some very creative people and
the private sector figured out how to
dig up meet it go around it scale it
with special new tools that's how I
think of digital media hi I'm Matt Welch
for recent TV i am at Freedom Fest in
Las Vegas and I am happy to be joined by
Jeffrey Tucker the executive editor
editor of lazy fair books now you've got
a new book coming out called bill more
of gatekeepers right what's the is there
a long and impossibly a terrine subhead
on that it seems to be the trend yeah
and sure enough it's how to create your
own civilization in the digital age yeah
ok it's not so bad so it does what what
do we mean by create your own
civilization meet our own micro
civilizations really consists mostly of
the information we we get the
information we give the things we we
learn on a day-to-day basis in the old
days we were very restrictive in this
respect I mean there were all these
gatekeepers taunts what we had enough I
was growing up there were three channels
you know and like three different phases
broadcasting the same news for 30
minutes every night rule I mean it's
hard to even imagine it ever existed is
impossible to gentle wake up and wonder
if we're gonna just discover that the
iphone was like a big dream I mean I
sometimes write you know you worry you
wake up and enters this whole digital
thing is all big dream we imagine it as
far as I know where where you have to
pinch ourselves from contract but look
we are living in a dream world and that
world's been
by private enterprise and
entrepreneurship there's the
counter-argument to that is that you
know it no more gatekeepers has
completely hurt these important
institutions that that do more than just
gatekeeping I mean newspapers they're
important they're our lifeblood of
democracy i am told very often so I find
that I'm perspective yeah you know
here's the thing like every time history
moves every time there's a change in the
world is always a sector of society that
panics oh my god everything's falling
apart things will never be the same
again and it's wrecking our lives
forever and it turns out to never be
true I mean the music industry panicked
about I mean everything beginning of
recording you know tape recorders and
you know mp3 s in peace mp3 CD I mean
every change in technology causes some
industry to freak out and say the end of
the world is not and it never happens I
mean we've seen a greater explosion
everything we love in the digital age
and ever before and I'm I really mean
this pertains to every sector of society
like for example I'm a fanatic for very
strange music that very few people
really care about mostly ate through
16th century European chant and
polyphonic music very strange very
obscure right I can have all of that
that I want right now at the touch of a
button it's unbelievable this generation
here's more of this music than anybody
ever do it in the 15th century and 16th
century I mean it is like universal eyes
and everything has been universalized
the information has been totally
liberated in the digital age and that
that's what you want I mean let's say
you set out to run the world do you want
the physical world or do you want the
world of information which of the two is
more powerful I mean the way the
nation-state works it proves the
physical world in which they control is
actually not that powerful they've never
been able to conquer Iraq they haven't
been able to conquer Afghanistan they
haven't really conquered the US in the
way they wish
the world information is where the real
action is and that is owned by you and
me and especially in digital age we've
been empowered in that respect but we
live in a time when government is bigger
than it's ever been we've doubled
federal spending in 10 years nominal
terms and and government has more
technical control over our lives or
potential control we're all committing
three felonies a day you know the story
I do so what does this world that is so
bountiful and wonderful have to say or
how does it affect this was like we're
all standing in front of this mountain
and it's called government and we don't
know what to do with we can scream at it
and say go away go away go away it's not
getting us very far there's some very
creative people and the private sector
figured out how to dig up neath it go
around it scale it with special move
tools that's how I think of digital
media it's allowing us to track the
state better find workarounds stay in
contact with each other in a way which
the state probably objects but we've
been able to do it through creativity of
private enterprise and commercial
society which has been working so well
in the digital age like never before
let's end on a future tastic note who's
the next gatekeeper to fall what are we
going to see what's power center that
stands in between us and our choices is
going to be eroded by how you think it's
I think it's nationalism you know and
every day it's breaking down more and
more the more I'm in contact with people
internationally more feeling of a
friendship to them the old language
they'll barrier used to be language
that's falling I mean how can you
believe this I mean people correspond to
me within the strangest language
strangest languages languages may be
inferred up my google translator I can
immediately see what they're saying more
or less and speak back to them in their
language and they can tell what I'm
saying more or less that's amazing I
mean so its national to I said that's
the next variable we're just the
beginning of that and really it's hard
to imagine but we're really at the
beginning of the digital age just the
beginners the future is going to consist
of amazing surprises who don't know
anything about right now on this great
and scintillating notes thank you very
much Jeffrey talking about books so much
for having no more gatekeepers for
recent TV I in that will
you